Kristen Bell's man Dax Shepard just
played Santa giving back to some very
deserving kids I am spreading holiday
cheer today in Los Angeles so you bump
into me you might get something and
that's not an invitation to stalk me but
it also is so I saw an Instagram you're
running around today tell me about these
random acts of kindness yes so I've
partnered with Amazon to deliver smiles
all over the city so we started here at
Children's Hospital Los Angeles and then
we're gonna be roaming the city kind of
just trying to make people's day
Dax delivered presents to young patients
at Children's Hospital Los Angeles
Center for rehabilitation can I sit with
you guys
fantastic he loves giving back but it's
also a teaching opportunity for his kids
Delta and Lincoln a part of it that is
motivate just by me being an okay person
but really now that I've kids you're
trying always to set an example for them
that you hope they'll emulate because
there's I'm setting other examples that
I don't want them to emulate so I got a
counteract we're in an interesting
situation where our kids are pretty
privileged and we weren't so trying to
instill in them what we kept along the
way okay we have a bunch and there's a
bunch of little people who don't have a
bunch I feel like you and Kristen near
two of the most giving celebrities in
Hollywood well listen is let's just be
clear ah no she's a better person than
me by a factor of at least six but still
even if I do 1/6 of what she's doing
that's a lot more than I ever thought I
was gonna do exactly and by the way -
told me they would not give him a role
in frozen - because he can't sing
[Music]